hello everyone this is peter cooper from
the ncbi
welcome to today's webinar on standalone
blast 2.9.0
and information relating to the database
5 format
so this has various titles a shorter one
is
using orders we're going to talk mainly
about using the organism information
with standalone blast
2.9.0 then the blast database 5 format
this is really a webinar that i've
already given almost a year ago
but we wanted to update you on some
things about blast db5
and just to remind everybody and to talk
to those who didn't hear us the first
time
about what you can do with blastdb5 so
what we're going to do today is give you
a little bit of the motivation behind
why we made these changes
talk about some of the features show you
how to limit your search by taxonomy
uh show you that you can search
sequences by accession faster
and we'll show you how to retrieve
sequences by taxonomy from a blast
database
i think it's useful to understand why we
made these changes
and the main reason that we did it is to
prepare for changes that are coming to
sequence identifiers
we're moving to systems that use
accession only sequence identifiers
rather than the integer gi's or the
integer ids which are called gi's i'll
come back to that in a few minutes
um there are also changes in the protein
chain identifier is coming from
pdb those are the proteins that are
coming from the structure database
um that mean we need to make some
changes in the database
so that's all very well and good and it
sounds a lot like we're doing this
because we have to do it for our own
purposes
but you get things out of this one of
the things that you get is something
that i think people have wanted for a
really long time
that's to have the taxonomic information
built in
baked into the blast databases these
make your organism searches
much easier the database system that
we're using
lmdb enables faster lookup of accessions
and other string identifiers
you will also get access to proteins
from gilas projects we'll talk more
about that in a couple of minutes
we're now producing proteins that do not
have gi's and
you can't see those in the old blast
databases and also
once we get the new pdb records with the
long chain ids you'll be able to access
those
in the blast databases so just let me
point out something to you
all of our software relies on these
integer identifiers there are various
ones for various databases
the ones for sequence databases are
called gi numbers
and they're these integers and all of
our systems have traditionally depended
on these integer identifiers
these are basically um ants in terms of
c plus plus programming language so
there's a limit
depending upon whether they're signed or
unsigned to two to four billion
the thing that i want to point out to
you is that we're already at about a
billion gis
so that means that we're going to run
out
and so this will be a problem and we
will have to re-write a lot of our
software
and so we're going to move away from
using gi's using accession.versions
instead
and because the number of gi's we have
left is
somewhat limited we're kind of
rationing those so for some projects in
particular a lot of the whole genome
shotgun projects that are coming in now
that we do make proteins for them we're
we've stopped assigning gi numbers to
those and so there's a whole bunch of
these
that you can see here in the sequence
that browser
they're nucleotide and protein sequences
that do not have gi numbers
what this means is that you can't find
these things by searching in nucleotide
and protein web resources by using
ordinary queries you can find them by
their identifiers and pull them out
and these things the proteins in
particular are not going to be present
in the v4 glass database the old version
of the plastic
just to point out many of these proteins
are coming from the pathogen detection
project which is this collaborative
project between a number of government
agencies
that's involved in identifying and
analyzing foodborne illness outbreaks
um so this is one of the major sources
of gis proteins and these are important
proteins of course because these
organisms
are important and their proteins are so
you need to be able to have access to
those and that's why you need to move to
the new
blast version and the new blast database
version
what's been up for a while at ncbi is
a sort of a not quite fully db version 5
database which means that it does have
gi numbers in it
in order to work with the fully gi less
database you're going to need to upgrade
both your blast binary to 2.9.0 and to
get the new
pb version 5 databases the executables
for 2.9.0 are available in the usual
place
on the blast ftp directory in the latest
directory in the latest link in the
ftp directory there for executables um
2.9 will still work with version 4
databases i just want to point out that
we will stop
updating the version 4 databases
eventually and i think we're thinking
about stopping after
september of 2019. in order to work with
the newest
v5 databases which are not yet on the
ftp site
you will need to upgrade to 2.9.0 the
updated gi list databases
for v5 should be on the ftp site
we're thinking may 20th then just i have
a little footnote here although it's not
something that i want to advertise
as a great thing the side effect of that
we're using these on the web right now
is that you'll notice that you can't use
entre limits anymore
the organism limits are still there and
that's the thing that most people
need and speaking of that you know the
thing that i always tell people when
they do a blast search on the web is
the most important thing you can do is
to limit by organism
and you can do that by typing an
organism name in the bottom here
of the blast form where it says organism
to either include or exclude
various taxon on standalone blasts the
way you would manage this in the past
has been traditionally by gi lists and
that's not going to work
anymore with the version 5 databases
so in order to do this you can do some
other things
that don't require using gi's one is to
use a seek id list
seek id lists can be accession so you
can use that accession.version
a list of those to limit to a particular
set of sequences in the database you can
also
exclude things using a negative seek id
list again this can be a list of
accessions that you don't want to see
and then there's a whole set of things
that have to do with the baked in
taxonomy that's in the database
so you can search for a particular tax
id
or a small list of them that you can
pass as an argument
or you can pass them as a negative
argument so you want to exclude certain
groups of organisms
or you can upload a file of tax ids
to either include or exclude from you
these things work on the
search programs for blast db cmd which
is the
the program that you use to extract
things from a blast database
you can retrieve tax ids sequences for
particular tax ids or a list of tax ids
directly using blast dbcmd you can also
looking at any of the databases that are
in v5 format you can get tax info it
tells you
what packs that are in there and how
many sequences each taxa
has so how do you get a list of tax ids
you can do that on the web fairly easily
so you can just go to
the taxonomy database here at ncbi and
you can search for example
a set of organisms so i'm getting all
the tax ids for green plants in this
particular case
and download that and i could even do an
exclusion if i wanted to get a
particular set of
tax ids in this case for green plants
without the monocots in there
so you can create a file and download
that and use that to limit your search
in this case this is about 209 000 tax
ids which really
that's not too bad you can download that
in a few seconds
you can also do it from the convenience
of your command line
with a shell script that comes with the
blast
release now and it's called get species
tax id and it's a shell program
you can either input a name to get back
a tax id or you can input a tax id to
get all the tax ids concluded in the
taxon
this uses our edirect package so you
have to have that installed
and for that reason it only works for
unix linux and sigwin
only at this point so you don't have to
use this to get those taxis as i showed
you you can do them from
the entry system but it's pretty
convenient to do it and so here are some
sample command lines that
you know that use these various new
options that are available now
and we'll go over some of these on the
command line here
and directly so i won't go over these by
reading them aloud to you i don't think
that's very helpful but the slides are
there
and you'll find that if you look at the
slides that i gave you there's a couple
of extra slides in there that i did use
when i gave my talk today okay so let's
go back
and we'll do some live demos which is
always exciting because they don't
always work
something may go wrong but that's fine
we're going to look at a gi less protein
just so you can see if
these things really do exist we'll get
some tax ids for
soybean flowering plants and actually i
think i changed that up i think i
used the pea family instead of flowering
plants because there was such a large
set
and we'll limit we'll show how to limit
applies a blastp search against
nr to those particular taxa we'll show
you how to extract
uh certain sequences from nr using the
tax id list
and we'll show you how to use a seek id
list that's been converted to a binary
form
so that it works much faster so i'm
going to escape out of my slides here
and i'm going to move over to a command
line window and what i'm going to do is
switch back and forth because i can't
type very well so i'm just going to copy
i have the text file up on the ftp side
you could certainly look at it and it's
in your
handouts there as a word document um so
you can see the command lines there if
you want to i'm just going to copy paste
those when i need to
so we can see them in action
so let me get a terminal window up here
so what i'm going to do is switch back
and forth between this
my web browser so the first thing i'm
going to do
is just to show you that there are gi
less proteins in the database
and this is the what i'm doing is
pointing at a copy of
the nrv5 that's on our system here so
this is just a typical use of blast
dbcmd to get out
fasta format for this particular protein
this is one of these proteins that came
from our pathogen detection project
and this is one of these on drug
resistance proteins
from um salmonella and tarika now
how do i how do i know that that's a gi
less protein well one of the things i
can try to do is just
let's see if we can pull it out of the
version 4 database and i
just pointed at before here and you can
see that that doesn't work
and there's a bunch of there's a couple
other command lines that i won't waste
your time with but you can show that
there really aren't any gis in this
database in the real db5 database
which db version 5 database which
remember is not yet available on our ftp
site
so let's go ahead and move on and we'll
do some of the
basic things we talked about a minute
ago
so we'll switch back and forth here a
little bit i'll go ahead and
open a new tab over here
what i'm going to do is do a search and
i'll go ahead and just load this
directly but this is what i could do in
taxonomy
to get tax ids
so you can take any organism name go to
our taxonomy database
this is a species level tax id which is
what you're going to need to work with
the blast databases
and really it's the leaf node tax id so
i could have the tax id is
3847 so i can easily find that on the
web if i want to
i could also do it command line style if
i want to and i could also use
the script that's provided with
the blast database the blast
distribution
and we'll see that in just a minute
notice that i can also get
all the tax ids for a particular tax on
by going
and searching for the p family for
example
and so that's the entree query that i
need p family and that subtree in square
brackets
and it gives me 13 000 tax ids i could
then save these to a file
i want to change this to dax id list
and then i can create the file and i've
already done that so that's all my
little directory that i'm using for the
webinar
to save time i won't go ahead and
download that
we can also do the same thing using the
script
let me go back over here
so here's our get species tax id shell
script
just like many of our blast programs you
can just type help at the end of it to
get
options this is a pretty simple script
the taxonomy id is one of the arguments
i can give it or i can give it the name
of the organism
that i'm interested in
so let's say i want to do the p family
which is a fairly large group of plants
so that's the tax id and now i can use
it to get all the tax ids
that i would need to make my list
same thing that i did on the web a
second ago
what i'll do is i won't bother to
redirect that to a file right now
i'll go ahead and just
show you part of the output
so you just get that long list of tax
ids
in fact that file is here so i can just
count how many are in there
and that's the same number that we had
on the web 13 176.
okay let's do some other more
interesting things now let's go ahead
and limit our blast searches to a
particular
text id
and so let's search the nr database and
i've got a bunch of options here on the
command line
that are useful ones we've got a
particular kind of tabular output
and this will be searching only those
tax ids this is the soybean tax
id uh and i've got this geyser
saccharomyces protein argo that i'm
going to search against that with
um and i'll go ahead and just put the
output to the
terminal just because it'll be a little
faster now this search
depends on how many people are using my
class machine here as to how fast this
is going to be so let's give it a shot
and see if it's fast today
just fast a few minutes ago and if i get
tired of waiting for it um i have the
results available so we can look at them
in a minute i'll give that about
15 or 20 seconds and then i'll go ahead
and bail on it and show it to you there
it is
so that's the head then the total output
this is a similar kind of thing and it
just goes on and on but we have
focused our search against nr only
against the proteins from glycine max
which is the soybean
likewise i can do the same thing for ps
in this case i'm using the tax id list
let's just redirect the first and lines
of that to the output
let's see how fast this one is this is a
little bit more
data i'll give that about 20 seconds to
and if it doesn't get done i'll just
cancel it and show you the output
that i've already saved
so that was pretty fast now admittedly i
have a pretty
machine with a lot of memory that i'm
using
but again we've we see other members of
the p family in this case the first
few here are from the genus glycine same
as soybean but it's a different species
so suppose we wanted to to get out all
the soybean
proteins that are in
the nr5 database we can easily do that
here
so i'm using blastdbcmd and this is one
of the command lines that was in my
slide
so i'm just going to tell it to give me
all the fasta formatted sequences and
i'm not going to show you
the whole output but i have the entire
file already done
just to see the trade that this does
work
there's the first couple of them right
there
i can do exactly the same thing with the
p family uh it doesn't really add any
additional information so i won't
demo that one for you but it's in the
handout if you want to try it yourself
so the last thing that i want to show
you is
make an accession list and then using
using that to
focus your search on a particular set of
sequences and what i'm going to get is
the list for the
human non-model refseqs and i've got the
query right there that you would use to
get these and this is actually a pretty
fast way to get them
i'll just show you that on the web
there's 53 000 of these you can easily
download these to a file
and what you want to do is to get your
accession list and i've already done
that so that list is on
uh my little directory there
there's another way you can do it you
could also use edirect to do this and
the edirect command line is
also in that handout i'm not going to
bother to run that
and so i could do edirect exactly the
same way
so i have this um file on here this is
human nonlineal accessions and these are
going to be the np style reference
sequences
so there's the first 10 of them
there's 50 some thousand in there and
then what i want to do
is create a version 5 c
id list and this uses the blast utility
that comes with glass it's the
blastdb alias tool it's going to make
this binary seek id
list file that we're going to use to
limit our search
okay and that file is there
there's my non-model seek id list right
there
the last thing i want to do is just run
that search it's the same kind of
options that we use for all the other
ones
and again i'll go ahead and put this to
standard output instead of putting it in
a file
okay so that worked just fine
so now let me just go ahead and go back
to my slide set here
so we showed you that the improvements
that we've done to last
2.9.0 and db5 works faster with string
lookups it's much easier options for
taxonomic filteries
works faster with accession list and
this remember that this is required for
the true gi list databases that are
coming soon
uh and i'll leave you with a few urls
here for um things that we talked about
in the webinar and places to go for
additional help
for example our youtube channel is up
here so that's where this
recording is going to be and i'm going
to leave it open for a few minutes for
questions i realize that we're pretty
much at time but i can continue
to answer questions if there's anything
that so dave arnold is here and he's
going to read me the questions
someone asked them about uh genome
databases when are they going to be
in a glass dvd version 5.
that's a good question for christian the
answer
so that means that the the genome
databases are not going to be available
in version 5 for a while now the
proteins associated with those are in
the regular protein database so those
are going to be in there now
okay another question is what would you
recommend for finding or narrowing down
tax ids when you are looking for
uh an order of like animals when the
taxonomy listed in the database is not
correct
for some of the uh entities when
you do an alignment yeah i'm not sure i
understand the question completely i
mean
whether so one thing one thing to say is
whether or not our taxonomy is
correct or not what you know people
think about the classification organisms
doesn't really matter so much because
it's just what we use so
um you would have to use the tax ids
that we use for that particular group of
organisms
so that's all i can recommend is that
you're gonna have to use our tax ids
because those are the ones that we've
assigned to the sequences whether or not
those are the
true classification system is open for
debate but
i'm not sure if that answered the
question or not the next one is
is it possible to filter by uh type
species
or type strings yes that's possible to
do
by um making an accession list of those
things
i don't know that that's an option to
search for the tax ids in the
taxonomy but it may well be yeah i don't
that's a good question and i'll tell you
what in the document we'll i'll look
into that
and answer that in the quest and answer
document i know you can do the kind of
search in protein for example
to get sequences from type
and that's that's really just for
efficiency right question if we stored
all those
the lineages it would just be too much
there's just just too many nodes in
there
when we did this in the demo we we
limited to the p family for example and
you can do that
but you do have to get all the leaf node
tax ids
so anything that's in the question spot
we will address
in the document that's going to be
provided in a few days
okay so thanks everybody for coming and
that's
uh that's going to conclude the webinar
for today a nice talking with you and
we'll
talk to you next time thank you